that's my job as an actor and that's
what I want to do Nicole Kidman gets
candid about the emotions that tend to
rule her life as an actress the big
little live star Wow's on the cover of
Marie Claire's October issue inside
Nicole opens up about playing a game
with her husband Keith Urban where they
asked each other whether an artist leads
with their head heart or sexuality do
you go and write stories up as for the
51 year old actress she's a good mix
when performing telling the mad quote
but I'm probably dominated by my heart
if you don't come from a feeling place
you just end up with an enormous amount
of technique I have this line but that
can be overruled
it fluctuates too I have a strong
sexuality the Emmy winner admits one of
her strongest emotions is crippling fear
but motherhood has changed how she
combats it quote I think once you have
children your resilience is built and
your ability to go okay I can't wallow
and I certainly can't get into bed for a
week and never get out I mean my kids
are always like what is she doing now
[Music]